yo what is up everybody mad the Ouija
here is another fallout 4 video now in
this video i'm gonna be showing you guys
how to duplicate any item and more
specifically how to get infinite or i
guess just up to 10 special stats in
every special stat so what you're going
to want to do is get to your special
book now this is a book that can be
found in your home in sanctuary hills in
Sean's room i found it under this a his
little dresser thing i'm not sure should
be anywhere in the room find it and if
you already found that that's good you
already did step 1 so we're going to be
duplicating this book if you don't know
what this book is it gives you a sext
report in one of your special you get to
choose one and it gives you that we're
going to be duplicating this book and
prodding the special ability that gives
you to put a point in one of your
special perks so which go you're going
to need dog meat as a companion and with
the basically the general gist of this
is you're going to drop the book have
dog me pick up the book and then as he
picks up the book you're going to pick
it up as well I will know that since
you're duplicating just keep wanting
your inventory I was only able to do
this with one of my inventory so just
you can just not pick up the copies so
let's get into it you drop it SSE here i
have dog me go away so it's easier i
backed up from the book command dog need
to pick up the book and he comes over
stands as animation starts i pick up the
book as well he's going to drop the book
and i'm gonna have one in my inventory
now his doesn't really matter the one in
your inventory you drop you pick it up
again it'll give you your special point
his one you pick up up just doesn't do
anything at least in my experience that
that's how this glitch works so there
you go you have duplicated your item you
have gotten a special perk and you can
keep doing this up to for all your
special perks up to 10 and yeah that's
that's kind of the whole idea of this
thing you can use this to duplicate any
item in my experience I've duplicated
mini nukes I've duplicated fusion cores
which are two very important rare items
I don't know if this will work for other
magazines such as the just all the other
magazines that give you special
abilities I imagine it should but it
definitely works for your special and it
definitely gives you the special points
the points to put in your special perks
stats whatever they're called so yeah
this
is kind of forward this is for console
players as you can see i'm on the pc so
i could just use console commands
however for pc players they don't use
console commands because you're scared
you might mess something up or a xbox
one or ps4 player this is it this is a
great way to get special points all the
way up if you want to experiment if you
want to be super LP if you want to be
tough going into survival you're going
to be super super strong man this video
this trick is for you as you can see
it's still work and still swagga now and
yet that's basically the video for how
to duplicate anything and how to get 10
special points in everything you can see
here I have three agility I'm going to
go specifically on agility again and
then I will have for agility so you guys
will a little more proof that this works
if you don't already believe me so yeah
that's basically I guess that's the
entire video I hope you guys have
enjoyed watching this if you have make
sure you check out more of my follow-up
or contents I have put a lot of it i
will continue to put out stuff guide
tips and tricks the whole shebang and
don't know let's play so now not the
whole shebang so yeah I hope you guys
have enjoyed this hope you guys get a
ton of your your special perks I'll show
you guys some footage of me using this
for mini nukes and fusion cores too but
yeah that's basically it hope you have
enjoyed think I said that like eight
times now and yeah see you guys in the
next video peace out don't enjoy the
gameplay this just shown yeah bye
hey go get that
heads up bring it here boy head over